Transformers rise of the Beast
introduces an army of Autobots and
terracons to wage a new war for Earth
from Optimus primal to RC here are some
of the best Optimus Prime won't be the
only Optimist in Rise of the Beast the
film also features Optimus primor the
mighty and intelligent leader of the
Maximus who are robots that can
transform into animals rather than
Vehicles Primal essentially acts as a
Transformers version of King Kong since
he transforms into a hulking gorilla in
previous incarnations Primal is seen
growing into its role as the maximal's
leader often acting rashly in this film
though it seems like he's going to be
depicted as a seasoned leader who guides
Prime in the Autobots on unicron's Power
and arrival compared to Prime in the
trailer who already seems battle ready
Primal comes across as much more calm
and level-headed as he works alongside
the Autobots plus Ron perlman's Voice
work presents a tone of a strong leader
I'm not the one to fear Prime as a
prequel may be Prime's time with primor
helps him become the fearless and
determined leader fans know and love
either way Prime was sure to be a
pivotal force and Rise of the Beast
while fans are used to seeing bumblebee
team up with human protagonists rise of
the Beast as its Central protagonist
work alongside Mirage Mirage is an
Autobot spy who can transform into a
Sleek silver blue Porsche and project
Holograms he's mainly tied to
ex-military electronics expert Noah as a
fun and slightly rebellious Force within
the autobot ranks having Mirage voiced
by Pete Davidson might give the
impression that the character will
simply be comic relief the name's Mirage
come on kill tap however there are
plenty of ways that the autobot could be
much more than a simple jokester
mirage's transformation abilities seem
to be much more extensive than his
fellow Autobots which could make for an
incredible visual showcase a sequence of
Mirage transforming around nowhere while
in the middle of a Chase is visually
jaw-dropping and the idea of the
character being able to project
Holograms could be utilized for Unique
action sequences with Mirage tied to the
main character of the film it could also
be part of some big character moments
that show the robot's heart and yes
there will definitely be plenty of
one-liners from Davidson that will make
Mirage one of the funniest Transformers
brought to the big screen although RC
has had brief cameos and other films
like Bumblebee and Revenge of the Fallen
two plays a much bigger role than rise
of the Beast RC is a female law too but
with sharp shooting skills you can
transform into a fast-moving Ducati
motorcycle well most Transformers are
big and bulky RC is much more lean and
mobile making her a versatile threat in
battle RC's fighting skills are shown
off in the trailer when she skates
across a road like she's on Rollerblades
and Dodges missiles with these even that
RC is such a prominent character from
the 1984 animated series and does the
most iconic female Autobot it's
surprising that she hasn't been utilized
more on the live-action films however
the weights for RC's big debut seems
like it was worth it the film's visual
depiction of the character draws heavy
inspiration from her original look and
with someone like Liza koshy voicing RC
she's sure to have a memorable and funny
person anality that'll make her a fun
favorite one of Optimus primal's top
soldiers and closes confidence is air
razor a maximal scouter can transform
into a giant Falcon normally air razor
is known for working with another
maximal nined tiger Tron who can
transform into a tiger the two have been
able to merge to become the mighty tiger
Hawk however tiger Tron seems to be
absent in Rise of the Beast so air razor
will likely take on a new kind of role
that fans aren't used to seeing her in
based on the trailers air razor seems to
be a unique part of action sequences as
a terror in the sky for enemies she also
seems to be close with Optimus primal
and helps him make pivotal decisions
we must trust each other to protect the
home we all share
fans could be looking at a much more
seasoned and mature air razor who has
taken on a prominent leadership role in
the maximals and with the voice of
recent Oscar winner Michelle yeoh behind
airraiser she could be a very memorable
supporting character that acts as a
force of reason with the maximals while
Unicron played a silent role in the last
night the destructive planet-sized being
seems to be the main villain of Rise of
the Beast and hopefully we'll be able to
see his true form Unicron is the master
of terracons who seeks to destroy and
devour Earth to grow his immense power
he can transform into a mechanized death
machine that's the size of a planet as
well as a standard Transformers boss
fitted with sharp evil looking horns
throughout the trailers Unicron has been
shown in his Planet form and is a bit
concerning whether or not we'll see
Unicron in his epic robot mode remains
unclear could rise of the Beast make the
same and satisfying Choice with its
Larger than Life antagonist that Rise of
the Silver Surfer and Green Lantern did
with Galactus and Parallax either way
rise of the Beast seems to be unleashing
the Transformers franchises biggest
buddies for destructive World Tour and
unicron's presence means that the finale
fight has a ton of Epic potential
Scourge is a vicious right-hand robot of
Unicron and will cause the autobots and
the maximals trouble keeping earth safe
Scourge is a deadly Bounty Hunter who is
known for being a devastating force in
battle with this destructive combat
abilities Bertie can be foiled by his
arrogance he can transform into a mighty
semi truck like Optimus Prime even
though he's often subordinates a more
powerful Transformers like Galvatron and
Unicron he's also been known to lead a
clan of robot Hunters known as the
sweeps while it seems like Scourge won't
have the sweeps at his disposal he's
still going to be a formidable enemy for
the autobots and maximals to face with
unicron's power and influence guiding
him Scourge has a massive advantage over
his opponents and his vicious nature
could lead to some unexpected and tragic
deaths Unicron is definitely a big
threat in right of the Beast especially
if the sweep suddenly appear to Aid him
in battle
Scourge has a second in command of his
own in the form of night bird a Terracon
ninja who utilizes a bunch of different
weapons to be an absolute Terror to
fight although nice bird's name might
make something that she can transform
into a flying vehicle she instead turns
into a sporty Nissan Skyline GTR not
only does her dark purple color palette
help her blend into the dark sky for
nightmissions but a wide array of
weapons including sharp swords and razor
claws make her a formidable foil light
bird is voiced by Michaela J Rodriguez
the first transgender actor to be a part
of the Transformers franchise we haven't
seen much of my bird in the trailers yet
but her incredible fighting range and
story potential working under Scourge
could make her a fun favorite villain
another pivotal maximal within Optimus
Prime was ranks as rhinox a Transformer
that can turn into a mechanized Rhino
with big brains to match his intense
Brawn in previous incarnations rhinox
generally acts as a maximore's main Tech
expert and is often seen helping Primal
plot out strategies as his second in
command although rhinox has appearance
might make most think that is brutal and
vicious he can actually be a calming
Force for the Maximus yet his ear
piercing raw sharp horn and damaging
speed still making a formidable fighter
based on what we've seen in the trailers
rhinox takes more of a supportive role
within the Maximus as air razor seems
more like a firm number two for Primal
it would make sense since yo is a more
high profile name than rhinox's voice
actor David sobolov although he is a
seasoned voice actor within the
Transformers franchise still rhinox will
be a pivotal Force for the film's heroes
as his Tech skills will likely Aid
everyone at some point and anybody that
gets in his way will feel the power of
his mighty horn the maximors have their
own Scouts in the incredibly fast-footed
and fierce cheater who can transform
into a mechanized cheetah she Taurus
initially seen as the team's ambitious
and determined rookie before he rises
through the ranks and excels in battle
with stunning agility and speed cheat
all sneaks up on enemies and launches
surprises Souls thanks to his incredible
speed that's what makes him one of the
deadliest maximals in the Transformers
franchise
stranger danger stranger danger outside
of seeing cheetah race Bumblebee in his
vehicle form there hasn't been much of
cheetah in the release footage of the
movie so it's tough to say what kind of
role he'll play would he be a little
more mature and integrated within the
group by this points or he'd still be
their energetic rookie what we do know
is that he's going to be a part of some
lightning quick action sequences that'll
be thrilling to watch as he helps the
maximals and also buds to feed scourge's
forces while we haven't seen the species
of Transformers generally called Frieza
and the trailers and there isn't a voice
actor listed for one this species
appearance in the film's toy line
suggests that one will appear in Rise of
the Beast it's worth delving into what
these small Terracon Insight light
Transformers are and what they can do
especially since it's vastly different
from other Transformers mentioned so far
rather than transform into a vehicle or
animal frieza's transform into weapons
that can attach to Scourge and fellow
Terracon soldiers in battle Versa Fraser
is the ultimate enhancement for fighting
and can often help the terracons turn
the Tide while waiting War a small
species with multiple arms for Swift
Battlefield movement freezers will
definitely pose a formidable challenge
Scourge May command one Frieza or an
entire Army but either way these quick
weapon upgrades would make the terracons
among the most powerful foes that
Optimus Prime and the Autobots ever
encountered
oh it would be nice to believe that the
Autobots can Traverse the world without
some help they're assisted in this
globetrotting adventure by another
Walter barter named Stratosphere
stratosphere is a gigantic Autobot that
can transform into a cargo plane which
is extremely helpful for chauffeuring
the Autobots from place to place because
of his aerial abilities Stratosphere
generally prefers to be up in the sky
and away from the action but that
doesn't mean he's opposed to helping his
fellow Autobots when they're in danger
not much has been seen of Stratosphere
in the trailers aside from a quick shot
of him flying but that's not too
surprising Stratosphere will likely play
a supporting role in the film delivering
some assistance when needed and some
good one-liners here and there another
Tara County will fight for Unicron
alongside Scourge and light bird is
Battle trap like nightbird battle trap
features an anime inspired look and
comes with some unique weaponry and
skills he can transform into a tow truck
and mainly uses a ball and chain weapon
to ensnare enemies or beat them down
battle trap is a multi-faceted threat
for anyone who stands in his way and a
key player for the terracons and their
bid to take over Earth it's unclear what
kind of role battle trap will have in
Rise of the Beast since he hasn't been
featured much in any of the trailers but
there's no doubt that it will be by
Scourge and light Bird's side once they
come to Earth it seems like the kind of
warrior that skirt would want in his
army and will likely end up causing a
lot of Destruction battle trap might
only have a small role compared to other
Transformers mentioned here but he could
be a strong force within the Terracon
ranks that makes them the most fearsome
faction in the franchise